what were like the the core activities
that clearly you did consistently most
of the time that resulted in you winning
the year I think it actually again goes
right down to the first thing which is
speaking to the most people that you can
the reason that that was beneficial was
because if I didn't have anything for
them right at that moment a month later
we'd bring on a role and I would go back
to my talent pool right I think these
three could be good for that get in
touch with them doing everything you can
and thinking about what roles you could
bring on in two months time but speaking
to that candidate and thinking it's
still worth your time in that moment cuz
it's so easy when you're working on
certain accounts to be I'm only going to
speak to people that will be right for
this role you need to think outside the
box and think but in two months I'm not
going to have these roles they're going
to be gone so I need to speak to people
that are going to be potentially good
for other stuff